this video is brought to you by talk in
arabic the only place where you can
learn
any of the major dialects of spoken
arabic if you want to learn arabic the
way it's really spoken
click the link in the description
indonesian and malay
which are basically two varieties of the
same language are members of the
austronesian language family
but due to contact with other cultures
through trade religion and colonialism
they've been influenced to a great
extent by other languages
their major influences include dutch and
english depending on
who colonized the area sanskrit as well
as persian and
arabic today there's a significant
number of arabic loanwords in indonesian
and malay
not only formal literary and religious
vocabulary
but lots of common words used in
everyday conversation also come from
arabic
if you stick around until the end of the
video i'll tell you exactly how many
arabic loanwords there
are the middle east and north africa are
far from southeast asia
so how did arabic influence malay
nusantara
which includes present-day malaysia
indonesia brunei and singapore has been
a hub of international trade since as
early as the 4th century
most notably the strait of malacca
contact with muslim arab traders goes
back as far as the 7th century
and they were later followed by muslim
missionaries some of them from the
indian subcontinent
and some of them from the arabian
peninsula islam became widespread by the
14th century
partly through the conversion of local
traders but in large part by converting
and
intermarrying with members of the ruling
classes which caused much of the
community to imitate their leaders and
convert to islam as well
during the malacca sultanate which was
founded in the year 1400
the spread of islam accelerated and
malay became widespread as a lingua
franca of trade
malacca also became a busy international
port city
resulting in more borrowings from other
languages and this is probably when some
of the more conversational arabic words
entered the language
and during this period the influence of
islam and islamic literature
brought more formal arabic vocabulary
into malay let's look first at some of
the religious vocabulary that was
borrowed from arabic the word for god
allah in malay and indonesian this word
is not only used by muslims
it is the general word for god and is
also used by christians
though in malaysia there has been some
controversy about that
masjid or in malay masjid the word from
mosque
from arabic masjid iman the word for
faith
from arabic iman ibada or
ibada meaning worship from arabic
in indonesian this is the word for a
head scarf covering a female's hair
head and shoulders in arabic the word
gilbert
refers to a type of long outer cloak
that covers the whole body
haram the word meaning forbidden or
illicit
from arabic haram one interesting
borrowing is the word
kitab from the arabic word kitab in
arabic this refers to any book
but in malay and indonesian it normally
refers to a holy book
including the holy books of other
religions though sometimes it refers to
a different kind of book in a very
literary context
for example a dictionary may sometimes
be referred to as
kitab logat this word logat also comes
from arabic
luga the word for language in malay and
indonesian it can mean an accent or
vernacular
so this phrase means something like book
of vernacular
but the usual word for dictionary is
kamus which is also an arabic loanword
from arabic
kamus there are a lot of simple everyday
words like this that come from arabic
salamat this word means safety or
well-being
it comes from arabic salama meaning
safety
this word is used constantly in malayan
indonesian because it's used for
greetings
such as salamat pagi meaning good
morning
it's also used with the meaning of
congratulations
to ask someone how they are in malay you
ask apocabar
meaning what's the news this word khabar
means
news when referring to personal news
this comes from the arabic word for news
to say sorry in malayan indonesian you
say ma'af
this comes from the arabic word meaning
exemption
so it's like saying please give me an
exemption from punishment or
please let me off the hook the malay and
indonesian word for time
like time in a general sense is waktu
this comes from the arabic word for time
this word means moment or time in the
sense of
at the time of it comes from arabic
meaning hour or time and nowadays watch
or clock too
a little side note here notice that this
word saat
as well as salamat end with the t in
malay and indonesia
even though they end in an ah or a sound
in arabic
why is that well it's because those
arabic nouns end in a t
sound when they connect to something
after them like a case ending
or another noun in a genitive noun
phrase like
ahmed's watch for many words the
connecting form was borrowed rather than
the base form
kurusi the word for chair this comes
from arabic
the word for paper is karitas this comes
from the arabic word
kritas which means a sheet of paper or
parchment
the word for problem masala this comes
from the arabic word masala
which means problem in the sense of an
issue or a matter
the word for body badan this comes
straight from the arabic word
badan which means body or trunk the word
for gift
hadiya this comes from the arabic word
hadiya
the word meaning poor miskin this comes
from the arabic word
muskin which means poor as in poor guy
like you feel sorry for someone
the malayan indonesian word means
monetarily poor
musim this word means season it comes
from the arabic word for season
mausim the borrowed word is also used
for the names of specific seasons like
mussim panas the term for summer
literally hot season
istirahat this word is a noun meaning
rest or break
or a verb meaning to rest or take a
break it comes from the arabic word
istiraha
malay including indonesian is a language
in which affixes are often added to
roots to create new words
so oftentimes arabic roots are
surrounded by malay affixes
daftara the noun meaning list is daftar
this comes from the arabic word daftar
but the malay word also serves as a root
word to which affixes can be added
mandaftar is a verb meaning to register
or enroll
mandaftarakan is a transitive verb
meaning to register or enroll something
or someone
the word meaning answer jawab it comes
from arabic
jaweb but then an affix is normally
added to the root
mun jawab zaya sudah i already answered
him
the root takes a verbal prefix and yeah
is an
object pronoun suffix meaning him in
this case but it could also mean her
or it there are numerous arabic words
that i hear frequently in indonesian
because they're used as transition words
or as
adverbials to move the conversation
forward or to identify
important information the words take the
suffix
which is generally used to refer back to
something that has previously been
mentioned or is understood
this is like saying i mean or that is to
say
you use it at the beginning of a
sentence when you want to clarify what
you mean
maksud this word means either intention
or meaning
it comes from the arabic word maksud
meaning intention or purpose
subanya this is like saying that's
because or
the reason for that is it's used to
express cause and effect
this word sabab means reason and it
comes from the arabic word for reason
sabab so anya this is like saying
the thing is it's used to tell the
listener that you are about to add some
important information about what has
just been said
this word sowal means problem issue or
question
it comes from the arabic word which
means
question or query um
this means in general um means general
common or public as an adjective or noun
it comes from the arabic noun
which means generality prevalence total
or
public as in the public this means at
first
or in the beginning awal means beginning
and comes from the arabic ordinal number
awal which means first
this means finally or in the end ahir
means end and comes from the arabic word
which means last as an adjective and end
as a noun
these words occur very frequently with
the suffix
but they're also common without it for
example akhir
it's also used as a verb meaning to end
and you hear the noun in all sorts of
contexts like
meaning weekend i listen to the news in
indonesian every morning and there are
certain words
of arabic origin that i hear over and
over
this phrase means natural disaster alam
means nature and comes from an arabic
word meaning world
corban meaning the victim's body in this
phrase both words come from arabic but
their meanings have evolved into
something different
in indonesian janazah means corpse or
dead body but in arabic it means funeral
janeza and in indonesian korban means
victim
but the arabic word quran means a
sacrifice to god
or a sacrificial animal uila
this word means territory or arya it
comes from the arabic word wilaya
which means province or govern it dunya
this means world it comes from the
arabic word dunya
america the united states the second
word here sarika
means union association or league and
comes from the arabic word
jarika which means company though its
original meaning when it was borrowed
was more like
a partnership or association honestly
there are lots more and i could stand
here all day listing them all
so let's move on and look at a few news
headlines and see if we can find
any arabic loanwords populasi badak
sumatra through sturon akibatsuli kawin
program by taboon jadisolusi this
sentence means the population of
sumatran rhinos continues to fall as a
result of difficulty mating
ivf program becomes a solution in this
sentence there is one arabic loanword
akibat akibat means result or
consequence
it comes from meaning consequence
the word kawin means to mate or to get
married
i found some conflicting information
about its etymology with one source
saying it came from the arabic word for
dowry
but it seems that it actually came from
persian
this sentence means the who says it
doesn't agree with countries making
covid vaccinations obligatory
in this sentence there is one arabic
loanword wajib which means required or
obligatory
the arabic word wajib is a noun meaning
obligation or duty
here the indonesian word has a verb
suffix that makes this a transitive verb
with the meaning of
make obligatory wajib khan
this means a number of ways to lose body
weight in two weeks that you can try in
order to support your diet goals
the first word is an arabic loanword
joomla meaning number
amount or total it comes from arabic
zoom le
meaning a series or collection or a
sentence or phrase
the prefix means one and is functioning
here similar to an indefinite article
another word from arabic here is badan
meaning body
which we saw before one word that might
look like an arabic loanword but
isn't is anda it resembles the arabic
second person masculine singular pronoun
enta but anda is not from arabic it was
introduced into modern indonesian and
malay in the 20th century
based on an obscure and archaic malay
word
as you can see there's a significant
amount of arabic vocabulary in
indonesian and malay but nowhere near a
majority of the words
in the camus daewon dictionary of the
malay language 1791 words come from
arabic
comprising 6.25 percent of the entries
some of those are uncommon literary
words though the number of commonly used
words is 1005
comprising 3.5 percent of the entries
but that 3.5 percent is not
insignificant
because it includes quite a few words
that are used constantly
the question of the day for speakers of
malay and indonesian did you know that
the words in the video came from arabic
do you have any other examples of arabic
loanwords and to speakers of arabic
are you surprised to discover that so
many arabic words are used in malayan
indonesian
leave your comments down below if you're
learning arabic there's a special and
unique program that i think you should
check out
it's called talk in arabic and it's the
only place where you can learn any of
the major dialects of spoken arabic
they have lessons resources and hd
videos covering each variety so you can
focus on whichever variety you're
learning
but you can also gain exposure to the
other varieties build an awareness of
the differences
and improve your listening comprehension
of spoken arabic in general
to check out talk in arabic click the
link in the description you can use my
code
langfocus for a 10 discount off any plan
and it's time to say thanks to the
langfocus patreon supporters who make it
easier to keep this channel going month
after month
i want to especially thank the ones
right here on the screen they are the
top tier patreon supporters so many
extra special thanks to them
and everyone thank you for watching and
have a nice
day
[Music]
you